[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: When you
use a Google service,
your information travels over
the internet between your app
and various points of
internet infrastructure
until it reaches
Google's servers.
Encryption helps
prevent attackers
from eavesdropping on
internet connections
and accessing sensitive content,
such as your credentials,
emails, and other personal data.
Do you know how Google
encrypts data to keep it safe?
Stick around, and
we'll show you.
First things first,
what is encryption?
Well, it's a
mathematical process
that takes legible data
as input and transforms
it so that it's unreadable
to unauthorized parties.
The encryption algorithm
used is public,
such as the Advanced
Encryption Standard, AES.
But execution depends on a
key, which is kept secret.
To transform it back
to its original form,
you need to employ the key.
Google encrypts your data
when it's saved on a disk
and when stored on backup media.
And this is called
encryption at rest.
It also encrypts data while
it is moving over the internet
or traveling between
data centers, which is
called encryption in transit.
Starting with data at rest,
several layers of encryption
are deployed to
protect users' data.
Data is split into chunks.
Each chunk is encrypted with
a unique data encryption key.
These keys are
stored with the data
and encrypted inside of Google's
central key management service.
Google's key management service
rotates keys at least as
frequently as 90 days.
So in the very unlikely event
that a key were compromised,
it won't remain
valid for very long.
How about a real life example
to put all of this into context?
Let's say a video is
uploaded to Google Drive.
That video will not be stored
entirely in a single server,
but instead will be
broken up into chunks
and then copied for
availability and performance.
Each of these
chunks are encrypted
and have their own
unique identifier.
Each piece is then stored
across multiple servers.
As for data in transit, Google
applies several security
measures to help ensure the
authenticity, integrity,
and privacy of data in transit.
Depending on the connection
that is being made,
Google applies default
protections to data in transit
to a Google data center.
For example,
communications are secured
between the user and
the Google front end
using TLS, which is a
cryptographic protocol.
Data is encrypted and
authenticated in transit at one
or more network
layers when it moves
outside the physical boundaries
of a Google data center.
Customers in Google
Cloud, for example,
may have additional requirements
for encryption of data,
especially in highly
regulated industries.
And they have
additional options,
such as managing their
own encryption keys.
And because computers
get better and faster,
it becomes easier to perform
the complicated mathematical
computations needed
to break encryption.
Even the mathematics
behind this process,
known as cryptanalysis,
can improve over time,
making it easier to
break encryption.
And so, to keep pace
with this evolution,
Google has a team of world-class
security engineers tasked
with following,
developing, and improving
encryption technology.
Our engineers take part in
standardization processes
and in maintaining widely
used encryption software,
such as BoringCrypto
and SSL library
in Chrome Chromium, Android,
and a number of other apps
and programs.
We regularly publish research
in the field of encryption
so that everyone can benefit
from this shared knowledge.
If you want to learn more,
check out the links below.
And stay tuned for more on
discovering datacenters.